tonight republicans are calling
democratic proposals to expand the
number of justices on the u.s supreme
court
an assault on judicial independence
several democrats are bringing forward a
bill to add
four new seats to the supreme court
which of course would then be selected
by president biden and possibly
confirmed
by a democrat-run senate already seeking
to eliminate the filibuster white house
correspondent kristen fisher has details
on all of this tonight live from the
north lawn good evening kristen
brett there are a few things more
controversial in washington right now
than killing the filibuster
and packing the supreme court but today
a group of congressional democrats tied
the two together
by introducing a bill to try to increase
the number of justices
to 13 and they say they know it would
require
getting rid of the filibuster to do it
some people will say we're packing the
court we're not packing it we're
unpacking it
the chairman of the house judiciary
committee making the case on the steps
of the supreme court
that it's time to add four new justices
to the highest court in the land
democratic senator ed markey blames
republicans the republicans stole
two seats on the supreme court and now
it is up to
us to repair that damage but
republicans say look no further than the
words of the late justice ruth bader
ginsburg
to explain why packing the court is a
bad idea
if anything would make the court appear
partisan it would be that
in 1983 then senator joe biden called
fdr's failed attempt to pack the court
it was a
bonehead idea it was a terrible
terrible mistake to make today
republicans on capitol hill
reminded now president biden of what he
said nearly 40 years ago
we may not agree on much when it comes
to policy
but president biden and i certainly
agree
on this point that it is a terrible
terrible mistake
to make it was a bad idea when ftr tried
to do it it's a bad idea
now on the campaign trail then candidate
biden said he still was not a fan
of adding more justices to the supreme
court i would not get into court packing
when pressed where the president stood
today the white house press secretary
said
his position has not changed but just
last week the president created a
commission to study
expanding the supreme court house
speaker nancy pelosi said today
that she supports it and shot down the
bill proposed by chairman nadler just
minutes before he announced it i have no
plans to bring it to the florida
the bill would face a steep climb in the
senate but senator markey made it
explicitly clear
how he intends to get it through we must
expand
the court and we must abolish the
filibuster to do it
is the white house comfortable with a
democratic senator explicitly
linking those two ideas from the steps
of the supreme court
the president believes that in freedom
of speech he has his own view
and he looks forward to seeing the
recommendations
from and that comes out of this court
commission
that commission now has about six months
to release its report
you heard the pal speaker say that she
wants at the very least
to wait until then but remember she
could always bring this bill to the
floor
at that point brett kristen fisher live
on the north lawn christian thanks more
on this with the panel